[Musica]
l'estate del 2003 fu un'estate
caldissima il figlio emanuele aveva sei
anni era un bambino e noi abbiamo un
piccolo stagno nel giardino di casa con
i pesciolini rossi viene da me con le
lacrime agli occhi mi dice papà corri io
cosa è successo ti sei fatto male
cornice un pesciolino rosso che sta
morendo non mi reco con lui allo stagno
vedo che il suo pesciolino avrò il suo
preferito stava morendo lo ha comprato
un paio di settimane prima studi un po
la situazione gli dico manuele più ormai
è spacciato per lui diceva no papà è
ancora vivo
poi ci pensa un po di nico bat
portiamolo magari e al fiume
abbiamo un fiume vicino a casa mi chiamo
gallardo vicino al lago di garda vicino
a salò
magari nel fiume riprende nuova vita lui
non voleva perché sapeva che l'avrebbe
perduto per sempre nel fiume pro ci
pensa dopo un po mi dice dai liberiamo
loro prendiamo un sacchettino di
plastica aver messo dentro l'acqua al
pesciolino abbiamo portato il fiume che
dista 200 metri da casa nostra
lì scendiamo le scalette c'è un bel
parco dove portavo emanuele da piccolo a
giocare lui si avvicina io in parte
ansioso perché tenevo la mia soluzione
cui lancia al pesciolino e questo
misteriosamente entra nell'acqua si
mette a nuotare felice felicissimo se il
papa genio davanti al figlio ma non
faccio tempo gongolare che parte
un'anatra dall'altra parte e si mangia
il pesciolino al volo tra l'altro mi
ricordo la scena non la ingoiato subito
lo tenevano ebbe come te lo portava via
emanuele dicevo le parolacce alla papera
diceva bastarda poi si volta verso di me
per trovare un po di consolazione di
comfort in unicam isbu dell'avo dalla
risata loro viva i pugni papa per caridi
figurate un bambino di 6 anni che su
pesciolino ma passano dieci anni e sono
le tre di notte e il 24 novembre 2013
io mi trovo in piedi davanti allo stesso
punto lo stesso fiume accanto ma c'è un
ragazzo di 18 anni circa che ho appena
conosciuto si chiama crisi che mi ha
appena detto che mio figlio manuel si è
buttato vestito un'ora prima
lì dove va buttato su pesciolino e io
sto 16 seriamente prendendo in
considerazione l'idea di seguirlo di
lanciarmi anche
ma qualcosa mi ha trattenuto nella mia
mente è passata tutta la mia vita mi
sono ricordato di quando avevo 13 anni
quando mio papà mi diede una tuta questo
mio papà io sono quello alla vostra
destra col cappellino ed una tuta che
stonava birra e mi disse dovrebbe
andarti bene e mi insegnò a lavorare
alla motrice la motrice una macchina
dove c'è una spazzola soprattutto
ginocchio di calcare contro tipo con la
pasta tipo vassoi e tutti specchiava in
entro questi prodotti bellissime ti
vedevi tutto nero e la cosa che odiavo
di più era quando la sera mi lavavo
facevo la doccia mi restava sempre in
nero dentro negli occhi proprio come un
pierrot e mi veniva la rabbia un giorno
quando avevo 13 anni proprio i primi
prodotti che lavoravo a noi salinità pd
salini suoi piccoli prodotti di acciaio
e mentre stavo lavorando entrare
l'officina del papà una piccola uffici
netta tutta nera un signore tutto ben
vestito con la giacca e la cravatta
io guardavo le unghie belle pulite lui
non c è ma solo in parte a me mi
guardava io lo guardo un certo punto
comincio a aumentare la velocità sempre
di più devo fare vedere chiaro filo che
lo bravo ovviamente veloce veloce
cominciamo sudare lui guardava
l'orologio ogni tanto poi mi guardava
riguardano logico riguarda guardare
l'orologio si vede che deve andar via
e in effetti dopo un po va via da prima
da mio papà poi mio papà mi chiama e
quella volta fu la prima volta che presi
un calcio nel sedere al mio papà perché
quel signore che nel nostro cliente mi
pagava a cottimo tanto pezzo quindi
aveva detto che lavoravamo troppi pezzi
allora dimezzato i prezzi a mio papà ha
pensato questa cosa mi ha insegnato che
nella vita dobbiamo sempre guardare le
cose da almeno due prospettive diverse
perché è così e poi a 16 anni
io avevo un sogno volevo diventare ricco
volo bagnare un sacco di soldi e per
esperienza perché prima di tutto non
volevo fare questo lavoro non avrei mai
voluto che i miei figli facessero quel
lavoro però volevo anche aiutare gli
altri sapevo che sul danaro si basava
tutto se io avessi intuito i soldi
chissà quanti bambini
potevo aiutare vedevo le foto di quei
bambini che provenivano dall africa con
le pance gonfie mi dicevo potevi essere
uno di loro
e allora ho studiato pato liceo
scientifico che ho fatto l'università
lavoravo aiuta con l'europa ha
registrato la lezione mela riascoltavo
con le cuffiette mentre lavoravo alla
motrice durante il giorno e così mila
euro 30 anni fa esatto in questi giorni
mi laureato in economia e commercio
immaginate questi pensieri che
attraversano la mia mente come
fotogramma della mia vita mentre io
guardo l'acqua laureato mi vedo giovane
laureato con la voglia di cambiare il
mondo con la voglia di dire la mia vado
a lavorare in un'azienda poi nell 89 mi
sposo però tre figli meravigliosi
alessandra emanuele giulia dall 89 al 93
comincia a cresce la mia carriera
diventò responsabile amministrativo di
un'azienda comincia ad arrivare i primi
stipendi interessanti ma niente rispetto
a quello che sarebbe successo dopo vado
a lavorare in un gruppo industriale che
a progetti molto ambiziosi diventa
amministratore delegato di numerose
società del gruppo mi occupo della del
reperimento delle risorse finanziarie
convinco un gruppo di banche a darci i
finanziamenti enormi facciamo un opa la
prima opa della legge draghi è
un'azienda quotata alla borsa di milano
la compriamo come gruppo diventa
amministratore delegato di quell azienda
nel 99 crei un azienda una dot.com di
cui diventò presidente da quotare in
borsa arrivano i fondi arrivano i soldi
quelli veri
nel frattempo meno comprato una villa
due ville tre ville quattro ville volevo
sempre di più di più di più le banche
visto che avevo patrimonio mi metterò a
disposizione altre linee di credito
perché scopri e quando hai soldi te ne
offrono altri quando non li hai ti danno
due dita negli occhi
e tu cosa facevi riempivi la linea di
credito comprabile azioni coi tuoi soldi
coi soldi che le banche ti davano oppure
di sempre di più diventare sempre più
ricco non poco alla volta mi stavo
perdendo mi stavo trasformando in quel
piero mi stavo davvero perdendo finché
arriva un giorno 11 settembre 2001 con
le torri gemelle crono tutte le borse in
un solo giorno
perdo tutto quello che avevo quello che
pensava di essere il più bravo è un gene
o era in ginocchio e quello è stato un
colpo duro pesante per il quale molti
miei conoscenti in quegli anni sono
tolti la vita
chi non si è più rialzato ma io ho un
motto
estote parati che significa siate
preparati mi sono detto qualsiasi cosa
ti accadrà nella vita dovrei sempre
combattere con dignità mai mollare mi
dicevo never give up ma e mollare ho
combattuto mille battaglie perché volevo
rifarmi un'azienda sì qualcosa mi sono
dimesso un po in piedi senza grandi
splendori mille battaglie ma ho
combattuto le battaglie sbagliate perché
quante volte si è arrivato a caso a
mezzanotte che i tuoi figli già
dormivano
quante volte si è arrivato a casa sei
più presto ti chiedevano papa facciamo a
lotte sul tappeto gli dice vino oggi
sono stanco sono stressato oppure su di
loro scaricabile a tua rabbia solo per
una giornata andata male per piccole
cose per cose banali
sì ho combattuto davvero le vostre
battaglie sbagliato è vero che mi sono
dimesso un ppe di ma poi leggo che prima
mi aveva preso è tornato alla carica
perché poi si prende la tua vita
personale arrivo un giorno del 22
settembre del 2012
vado da mia moglie dopo tanti anni di 33
anni che eravamo assieme dopo tre figli
meravigliosi dedico non ti amo più me ne
vado a me ne sono andato altrove
volevo smettere di combattere forse
volevo cercare la scorciatoia e mi sono
accorto presto che per fatto una grossa
cavolata
e confessa a mia moglie che sarei
tornato e di sì tornerò e avevo deciso
di tornare per la notte di natale per il
24 dicembre del 2013
quello era il momento giusto di trovare
mia moglie la mia famiglia a natale ma
quella notte quella notte mentre mi
trovavo in piedi davanti a questo fiume
mentre questo ragazzo era accanto a me
mancava ancora un mese natale del 24
novembre questo ragazzo meglio però
appena raccontato che emanuele andato
una festa con alcuni ragazzi più grandi
di lui aritmici maggiorenne i ragazzi 19
20 21 anni a quella festa è girato di
tutto alcol marijuana droghe sintetiche
emanuele aveva 16 anni e provato quella
robaccia lo hanno accompagnato a casa
secondo arrivato sulla soglia di casa
gli dicono gli amici vai a fare un giro
al fiume prima vai a prendere un po
d'aria così ti riprendi e quando
arrivato lì davanti al punto in cui
aveva lanciato il suo pesciolino in
parte al compagno chris gli dice io devo
uccidermi un amico tenta di trattenerlo
salutato in quel fiume mentre guardavo
il fiume e questo è il mio emanuele
aveva nei miei occhi i suoi occhi mi
ricordavo che proprio il giorno prima
ero andato a casa e l'avevo visto più
serio del solito diavoletto emanuele di
vedersi dobbiamo parlarci per te però
poi guardando l'orologio che adesso lo
porto più gli avevo detto oggi non ho
tempo per fermarmi ci risentiamo domani
perché devo sbrigare delle faccende e
domani era troppo tardi
ma qualcosa mi ha trattenuto ricordavo
di quanto ore manuele fosse un ragazzo
meraviglioso sì è vero che ha fatto una
grossa cavolata ma lui era molto
migliore di me
manuele non sapeva odiare non sapeva
tenere rancore e io a volte approfittavo
di lui quando lo rimproveravo non gli
parlavo assieme per tutto il giorno
perché sapevo che questo gli faceva male
volevo piegarlo della sera sapevo che
veniva da me bussava alla mia porta e
con le lacrime agli occhi mi diceva papà
scusami se volevo abbracciarmi io non
gli ho mai chiesto scusa per quello che
non mi sono buttato perché voglio
assomigliare a lui voglio perdere tutte
quelle cose sbagliate che siano radicate
dentro di me come padre come uomo
qualche giorno prima aveva detto papà io
non ho 16 anni tu non ne hai 50 dico
come si se ci pensi noi siamo
vecchissimi noi siamo abbiamo più di un
miliardo di anni
perché noi siamo l'evoluzione di quella
cellula primordiale che oltre un
miliardo di anni fa originato la vita
sulla terra
i primi organismi monocellulari questa
cellula si è voluta si è trasformata ed
è arrivata fino a noi non abbiamo un
miliardo di anni
è incredibile l'hanno trovato dieci ore
dopo ha negato lo hanno trovato così
forse aveva teso la mano per cercare su
opa che non c'era e sono tornato a casa
sono tornato a mia moglie dalla mia
figlia anche se i primi giorni questo
questo dolore mi stava schiacciando i
sensi di colpa per non essere stato lì a
tendergli la mano sensi di colpa per non
essermi fermato giorno prima i sensi di
colpi per colpa per non essere tornato a
casa in tempo però non si è mai buttato
con lui in quel fiume dopo dopo solo due
giorni nel momento più difficile in cui
la follia mi stava prendendo emanuele
venuto a salvarmi per la seconda volta
entrato dentro in un mio sogno sognato
che mi immergevo quel fiume
cercavo e non lo trovavo a un certo
punto l'ho trovato tenuto in fondo al
mare l'ho preso l'ho tirato fuori
dall'acqua aperto gli occhi e ho sentito
dentro di me una grande energia come se
lui come se la sua energia fossero
entrati dentro di me amo chiaro davanti
agli occhi cosa fare dedicare la mia
vita ai giovani andrà ovunque raccontare
attraverso la nostra storia
il valore della vita e quella notte alle
3 ho scritto una lunga lettera dedicata
ad emanuele nella quale si faceva una
promessa che avrei creato
un'associazione per aiutare i giovani e
così che nasce dopo pochi giorni la
fondazione e ma che sta per emanuele
pesciolino rosso e da allora ho
cominciato a dare in una scuola un'altra
quell'altra ottenuto 973 incontri in tre
anni e mezzo
in tutta italia sono andato da merano
fino al canicattì e isolato davvero
canicattì non è un modo di dire è una
città bellissima in provincia di
agrigento con 35mila abitanti siamo
passati da scampia comandate e marano di
napoli sono andati gratuitamente in ogni
scuola dove ci hanno chiamato abbiamo
pubblicato cinque libri sul rapporto
genitori figli sull'apporto a scuola
genitori figli sul valore della vita e
un regista un giorno l'anno scorso viene
da me un regista romano di opere
teatrali anche attore mi dice leggi
questo ha scritto un'opera teatrale
intitolata lasciami volare come il libro
nel cui è contenuta la lettera lasciami
volare è già andata in scena in sei
teatri pisa mio sogno ogni giorno
portarlo anche dentro
in questo bellissimo teatro quando vado
nelle scuole
parlo ai giovani ogni volta che
abbraccio un giovane
e come se abbracciassi il mio manuele ai
giovani si parlò anche delle dipendenze
ma soprattutto gli dico sì forse fate
anche l'istinto vostro di buttarmi via
di bere di farvi le canne perché magari
vi fa schifo questo mondo ci sono cose
storte però gli dico va bene buttatevi
in quel mondo ma ricordatevi che un
giorno mi sputeranno addosso
pp scieranno addosso e dovrete mettere
giù la testa e dico non sapete chi
vogliono controllare mettetevi in gioco
per cambiare per cambiare le cose
quello dovete fare cercare un sogno ed è
meraviglioso l'altro giorno proprio due
giorni tre giorni fa ero a milano
alla fine dell'incontro arrivato un
ragazzo di 18 anni e mi ha abbracciato è
scoppiato in un pianto e mi dice
giampietro aiuto mio nonno più un sogno
faccio le canne e ho cominciato a farmi
roba pesante proprio la settimana scorsa
io voglio uscirne aiutami aiutami a
trovare un sogno ma di fatto capire che
si ributta in quel mondo in quella
strada io non ce la farò mai ed è
meraviglioso questo sentire ragazzi che
ti dicono all'orecchio
mi hai cambiato la vita mi ha salvato la
vita io li chiamo i piccoli miracoli di
emanuele quando vado a parlare con i
genitori a quei genitori dico impariamo
davvero a non giudicare solo i nostri
figli non dobbiamo essere i loro
carabinieri ma dovremo riservarlo
guerrieri e di quei ragazzi eccoli qui
eravamo oronzo di cadore ai ragazzi di
fare la rivoluzione rep
cos'è la rivoluzione rap e resta per
ringraziare ringraziare ogni giorno per
quello che abbiamo e non ritenere tutto
scontato a saper aiutare gli altri c'è
qualcosa di meraviglioso nell'amore nel
donarsi nell'aiutare chi è più
sfortunato di noi non guardiamo sempre i
nostri singoli problemi ep poter
prepararsi prepararsi per cambiare il
mondo
amare innamorarsi della cultura perché
sarà la cultura che li rende liberi ma
la p il rapper il miur f2p vuol dire
anche perdonare il perdono ci libera dal
rancore che soffoca la nostra capacità
di liberare amore
sapete cosa fa chi non perdona se stesso
che come si scorge lascia dentro nella
proprio sensi di colpa nel dolore
e rimane immobile non si muove più a
liberarsi guardare avanti e mi sforzo
ogni giorno di perdonare di perdonare
anche me stesso perché l'unica cosa che
non possiamo cambiare il nostro passato
allora lo dice anche università
americana fred la skin la stanford
university insegna la materia del
perdono dice di ubud rather than
feedback fai del bene piuttosto che
stare male
ecco dico anch'io l'unico modo per
guarire dal male è davvero quello di
donarci e aiutare gli altri per cui
qualsiasi cosa voi abbiate dentro
qualsiasi senso di colpa qualsiasi
dolore qualsiasi frustrazione per aver
sbagliato rialzate t
guardate avanti non rimandate e questo
grazie
[Applauso]